ukraine and russia have ended their
first talk since war broke out five days
ago without any breakthrough a ukrainian
delegate says the negotiations were
difficult the meeting was held in
belarus close to the ukrainian border
the talks began later than planned and
lasted six hours but despite ukraine's
hopes for a ceasefire and a russian
withdrawal there was no agreement
major cities including the capital kiev
are still holding out but there's no let
up in the fighting our next report takes
you to ukraine but a warning that it
does contain disturbing images
the brutality of this conflict
in plain sight
medics say the people here were injured
as russian troops shelled the port city
of mariopol
one of them a six-year-old girl doesn't
make it
yet another pointless loss of life
russia says it's not targeting civilians
but pictures such as these which ukraine
says is a residential building in flames
in the northern town of chernehev seem
to disprove that claim
as do these satellite images showing
craters caused by russian artillery fire
near residential areas in the city of
kharkiv in the east
ukrainians say they will do all it takes
to defend their country
as civilians learn how to become
soldiers ukraine's foreign minister
makes clear the extent of his resolve
that they will never give up
he also had this appeal to people in
russia
i would like to address the citizens of
the russian federation look what
vladimir putin turned your country your
big country into he declared an invasive
war against ukraine he sent here your
sons husbands to kill ukrainians capture
our lands destroy our cities ukrainians
did not want this war but they will
fight for their land and their homes
residents are sheltering from the
fighting in an underground gym
many have been here for five days
despite what is happening outside some
are trying to be optimistic
there's hope for peace negotiations
because everyone wants peace and some
kind of result so that civilians aren't
being killed we're the majority here
for now though there is no peace and
this is the new reality for the millions
of ukrainians who just last week were
leading normal lives
some of the heaviest fighting has been
in ukraine's second largest city
ukrainian authorities say dozens of
people were killed and hundreds injured
when russian forces fired on residential
areas the emergencies ministry released
this footage showing flames and thick
plumes of smoke rising from apartment
blocks
authorities say the casualties could be
higher because the damage from monday's
shelling of residential areas is still
being assessed
and i want to bring in uh yevgeny varva
he is a ukrainian musician also known as
zakar koshma
he has fled kharkiv and is now on the
other side of the country in lev and i
want to welcome him to dw news and thank
him very much for joining us so you have
fled across the country but you still
have many contacts who are in kharkiv
what are they telling you about what
they are experiencing there
well i just uh first of all i would like
to thank you for inviting me to the show
i just had a conversation with my guitar
player who actually is still
staying in hardcave
today's news
we have uh several
districts in
harkief completely destroyed we have
high rises brought down
you have numerous people killed they
want to get some food they want to get
some medicine
but they were staying in lines
of course there's a big shortage in
supplies for civilians because
so we have lines
so at that very moment uh
russia committed uh what they committed
so you have managed to escape that
situation um from there can i ask you
how you personally made it to levive
i made it by car
uh
we do you live in the center of the city
me and my wife woke up and 4 30 in the
morning
uh
from explosions and
sounds of explosions and we did see
uh that with our own eyes and then uh i
have very old mama
and she is barely walks i also have a
kid who actually managed to break
his leg to a
month ago
so
in that situation yeah and that
situation i
made a very quick decision i jumped in
into the car i picked up my mother from
pablo vapor which is
a district
now being attacked
and there's a lot of uh
buildings destroyed right now with
civilians
so i jumped in the car uh picked my mom
uh
we put
whatever like brought was brought in
into our minds in detect the car and we
we went
uh i drove uh up to view for about three
days uh we slept in shelters
uh
actually across the country it's very
very impressive how
people from different cities help people
from different cities so everybody is
trying to help
uh
those people who are i'm so glad you've
been able to bring your family safely
with you across the country i just want
to ask how the situation in the vive
where you've arrived compares to what
you left behind
it's more quiet but
we are right now we are staying in the
hotel uh which was actually provided by
a company i work for
our
it company p2h so
the company
uh supported
uh
the employees and they rented a hotel
for several like three
30 or 40 people right now whoever had
the possibility to actually reach to
wolf
and be here for about two weeks now i
have to make decision
uh
obviously
yeah so i have to rent uh an apartment i
have a lot of things here well we wish
you the best of luck with the steps that
do come next thanks for speaking to us
under these really difficult
circumstances um the ukrainian magician
a musician excuse me you're gevnivarva
from indivu
thank you
thank you
so we can speak now with david schulich
formerly with the eu delegation in kiev
and now with kremlin watch investigating
russian influence and disinformation
operations against western democracies a
warm welcome to the show i want to ask
you first about the talks today between
russia and ukraine that took place in
belarus they ended with no major
breakthrough does that mean that there
is any chance going forward for a
diplomatic resolution to this conflict
i think that now both sides are going to
stick to their initial positions i mean
russians are requesting ukrainians to
completely surrender to demilitarize the
country to abandon their european and
nato related ambitions and this is
something which is absolutely
unacceptable for ukrainians
so the ukrainians are going to bravely
defend their own country their own
sovereignty and i think that russia
would put even more military pressure
now on ukraine and they will try to put
them you know
literally speaking on the knees and then
the talks might kind of resume so this
is a scenario that ukrainians don't want
to so you do expect to see more military
pressure despite the fact that we've
seen unprecedented western sanctions
that appear to be starting to bite i
mean surely the kremlin must be feeling
the pressure there
of course they are i mean we've seen
today the turbulent development on
the capital markets uh the the thing
that there was a devaluation of a huge
relation of a
rural
russian currency but this is not uh
still i would say a kind of a decisive
game changer that would force russians
to also make certain concessions i think
that we would rather see
another attempt to escalate the whole
situation
and as long as these sanctions really
don't kind of you know hurt the whole
economy of russia i think that president
putin will further escalate and will use
more and more military means and
military power against ukraine
now a group of eastern eu states have
backed ukraine's request to actually
join the eu um you previously were with
the eu delegation in kiev so in your
experience how likely do you think that
that
is uh well uh what is more likely than
uh the acceptance of the ukrainian
application for the membership is that
the eu would eventually and finally
grant ukrainian the uh
kind of a membership perspective that
has been on the table since 2013 the eu
was
always very reluctant to provide ukraine
with this perspective but uh under the
current circumstances i think it's more
likely that the eu 27 member states are
going to leave ukraine this perspective
because for the
eu membership the eu has its own formal
criteria there are certain procedures
and what ukrainians have asked for they
have asked for some sort of a fast track
uh you know
approach uh so this is something that i
don't think
some member states would accept
but still i talked today to some
ukrainian officials and they said that
if you want to get something you have to
always ask for more so i guess this is a
part of their kind of a negotiation
strategy
david schulich formerly with the eu
delegation in kiev and now with kremlin
watch thanks so much for coming onto the
program
thank you
the united nations opened an emergency
session of its general assembly with a
minute's silence for those killed during
russia's invasion of ukraine
u.n secretary general antonio guterres
warned russia that the fighting must
stop and he had strong words for its
president vladimir putin after he put
his nuclear forces on high alert
we are facing a tragedy for ukraine but
also a major regional crisis with
potentially disastrous implications for
us all
yesterday russian nuclear forces were
put on high alert
this is a chilling development
the mere idea of a nuclear conflict is
simply
inconceivable
conceivable
nothing can justify
the use of nuclear weapons
and to talk more about this emergency
session of the un general assembly i can
now welcome richard walker he's our
chief international editor
richard this session is still ongoing
what do we know has been happening so
far yeah well well powerful words there
from antonio guterres opening this this
um very unusual meeting they've only
been 10 sessions of the u.n general
assembly of this kind uh
ever um we heard that warning from from
him on vladimir putin's threat uh
surrounding nuclear weapons um and
guterres saying at this point enough is
enough there's been so much violence
already civilians are suffering that
it's really time for this to finish
already we also heard from the ukrainian
ambassador maybe we can talk about that
in a moment the russian ambassador went
through many of the talking points that
we've heard
from vladimir putin about how this is
all the fault of the ukrainians and
pointing the finger also at the west
um and it was also interesting to see
the chinese ambassador who gave a very
short and low-key
intervention
the chinese position has been really
interesting to watch because they're
trying to sort of straddle almost two
rather conflicting positions on the one
hand they're trying to
support the line of russia which has
become increasingly friendly with china
in recent years and particularly even in
recent weeks those two countries seeing
very much eye to eye that they want to
push back against the united states but
on the other hand china having to admit
that
it sticks to its principles that the
territorial integrity of sovereign
states which ukraine is uh cannot be
uh damaged cannot be infringed upon so
the chinese ambassador trying to walk
the line between those positions but
also saying that they really welcome
that these talks at least are happening
between the ukraines and the ukrainians
and the russians and richard you
mentioned that the ukrainian ambassador
also gave a powerful statement i just
want to see if we can pull up a clip of
what he had to say
if ukraine does not survive intention he
survived international peace will not
survive
if ukraine does not survive the united
nations will not survive have no
illusions
if ukraine does not survive we cannot be
surprised if democracy fails next
now we can save ukraine
save the united nations
save democracy
and defend the values we believe in
richard that's really a heartfelt plea
from the ukrainian ambassador but do you
expect we will see the international
community stand by
ukraine and against russia's um invasion
and aggression
well
i mean
we've already seen one vote taking place
in the u.n system at the u.n uh security
council a couple of days ago that has 15
members
the vote went 11 votes uh uh criticizing
russia
one vote in on russia's side russia's
own
surprise yeah and three abstentions so
that was already a sign that russia
is looking isolated
um of course this now opens up in this
session of the general assembly to all
193
member states
um so it's going to be very interesting
to see the degree of isolation that
russia experiences there particularly as
it opens up beyond uh the sort of power
centers of the security council to to
the entire world
um
so
i think the the supporters of this
resolution criticizing russia will
certainly want to have more than a
hundred votes uh criticizing uh russia's
position um but
we'll have to see it will it could be
tomorrow that the vote actually takes
place it could even be in when uh as far
through the week as wednesday and if
they do get that broad support that they
want and that they expect what will the
actual implications be for russia well
here's the difference between a vote in
the u.n general assembly and a vote in
the u.n security council if a resolution
had gone through in the security council
that would have had legal implications
uh for the russians the general assembly
has no such implications but it would
the the isolation if it does come to
that would certainly have
moral effects on the russians our chief
international editor richard walker
thanks as always for joining me in the
studio with that update
and ukrainian civilians have been
helping to resist the invasion people
are collecting donations and gathering
supplies for the army dw correspondent
mattias bolingar met some of the
volunteers helping refugees and soldiers
in the city of vinitza southwest of kiev
now poland meanwhile is preparing for
tens of thousands more migrants to cross
its border from ukraine after fleeing
the conflict there the polish border
guard says nearly 327 thousand people
have crossed into poland already some 73
000 people on monday alone now people
have been streaming across the border
since russia began its invasion of
ukraine the situation in some places has
turned into a humanitarian crisis
they bring everything they can spare
clothes food money as refugees move west
and soldiers east towards the front here
in vinitza and central ukraine people
are organizing aid for both
natalia who doesn't want to give her
last name leaves a youth center in peace
time she's used to organizing outings
and summer camps
now at war she's busy directing
volunteers and sorting donations
i never imagined i'd be doing any of
this i'm learning all the time we are
improving our work every minute we are
getting there
vinitza in central ukraine has so far
been spared heavy fighting although air
raid alarms are frequent
but like everywhere in the country
people here have been under shock since
russia attacked
now everyone wants to contribute a wave
of solidarity is running through society
natalia is out and about around the
clock the nightly curfew is the only
time she's not on site
i'm also definitely not leaving this is
our home that we love
and we're not going anywhere
not only about donating goods many also
contribute their time making camouflage
nets for the army
green and brown clothes are separated
from the donations and cut into pieces
the rest is a lot of handy work
the ukrainian army has been at war for
eight years still lacking many basic
items including protective equipment
and many here have somebody at the front
a husband brother sister
or in natalya's case a 19 year old son
we are in touch i can talk to him once a
day
it's those few minutes that i'm waiting
for all day
being active is also a way for many here
to deal with their worries
as we've heard poland is preparing for
tens of thousands of migrants to come
across the border from ukraine the
polish border guard saying nearly 327
000 people have crossed into poland
already some 73 000 people just on
monday alone the people have been coming
across the border since russia began its
invasion of ukraine the situation in
some places has turned into a
humanitarian crisis
ndw's correspondent max zander is in
poland at the border with ukraine max
high what is the situation for ukrainian
refugees who've been arriving there
right
so for ukrainian refugees who made it
across the border here to poland if one
thing has become apparent over the last
couple of days is that they are not on
their own no matter how hard the
situation here is the polish government
has prepared for this for days and for
weeks and has put a system in place to
help these people here
and let's have a look around at where we
are here right now we're in chemistry
the border town
a lot of the help that comes here uh has
been done has been carried out by
volunteers
who hand out donations as you can see
here um people here in poland but also
people from abroad have come here to
with uh with with donations uh with food
with diapers with blankets warm clothes
uh to uh brace the cold weather and as
you rightfully uh rightly pointed out
more than 300 thousand people are in
poland now um a few more
many more are expected
so all help is needed at the moment
absolutely it looks like a freezing
night there i know max you touched on
the fact that some procedures have been
put in place to make crossing the border
a bit easier for people coming from
ukraine i understand the government is
also talking about simplifying those
further can you tell us a bit more about
what that looks like
right crossing the border is still very
very difficult um hundreds of thousands
of people are fleeing uh from violence
in ukraine at the moment so there are
still long lines of cars at the borders
that are moving very slowly where people
spend hours even days in cars trying to
to to reach the border the train station
on the other side and live
the platforms are full of people people
are really having a hard time getting
onto those trains become very
competitive now one thing what the
ukrainians are doing on the other side
to speed up the process is we've been
hearing that they're stopping they're no
longer uh checking the documentations of
women and children and that is hopefully
going to speed up the process i'm here
on the polish side this is already the
case that anybody coming from ukraine
can come without having extra to go
through any registration or any
administrative process
and what have you been hearing from the
people you've spoken to who have just
crossed that border from ukraine into
poland
well
the situations are very different
naturally but what we've been hearing
from people we've talked to here
they're all very relieved to finally
have made it um people are people are
exhausted uh people are tired and and
just relieved that they made it here um
now um the first people who came here
over the last couple of days uh mainly
were people who had some sort of
connections here in poland amongst the
ukrainian community here now we're
seeing more and more people
who are just fleeing and they have no
real uh sense of orientation so that's
one thing that they have to do like
reassess their situation here and then
and see how they continue
and what can we expect in the coming
days as more and more people undoubtedly
cross into poland
it really depends and nobody really can
answer that question probably probably i
mean the situation is is evolving very
very quickly
on sunday alone we had a hundred
thousand people reaching poland um and
the government is preparing for for many
more
the polish prime minister um said that
he was actually moved by uh by the
outpouring of help uh by by the polish
people here and that poland uh is uh is
doing everything to help the refugees
which is a pretty much uh
uh 180 degree turn from what we've seen
in the past um how poland was dealing
with with people fleeing uh fleeing from
war but in this case the country is
determined uh to take everybody in as
many people as they can
be this one million or
perhaps many more that's an important
point there our correspondent max zander
thank you so much for your reporting
there